there's a precision that was brought to
the set so that visually it's just
stunning
what IMAX offers he was amazing big wide
shots with all this beautiful rich
texture and especially when you have the
juxtaposition between after than the
very brutalist cold backdrop against the
beautiful lush Hawaiian rainforest I
think that would sets and humans apart
from most anything else's on television
they're so well drawn because their
powers I don't I don't think of them as
powers I think of them as burdens you
take blackball he has a voice so
powerful it can shatter planets but
because of that he can't speak are you
speaking for yourself or for our King
though with Maximus to have an
antagonist whose primary motivational
force is that he's simply human that's
great
it was shot in IMAX format it was edited
for eyelashes intended to be eye
it should be seen on eyelash everything
has been specifically done to have this
grandiose experience and IMAX a sort of
the perfect place to put that on but
that what they do best
you
[Music]